اليكم بعض الاسماء البارزه في هذا التصنيف
ام كلثوم كوكب الشرق وايقونه الطرب العربي
في المركز الواحد والستين يصفها المقال
بانها لا يوجد مثيل لها في الغرب
مثلت روح العالم العربي لعقود ولا تزال
تمثل حتى الان الى حد ما فرانك سنترا صاحب
رائعه فلايمي تدمون ولذي رحل عام
1998 جاء في المركز التاسع عشر وصف بانه
كان عملاقا وراء الميكروفون وفاز بكل
الجوائز الممكنه في عهده
والى الترتيب
احد اساطير موسيقى الانبياء في المرتبه
الثانيه ولا تزال اغنياتها ضمن الاكثر
استماعا حتى بعد رحيلها باحدى عشر عاما
رغم كل الانتقادات لكن هناك اتفاقا على
احقيه المغنيه والشاعر الامريكيه الراحله
ريثا فرانكلين لصداره القائمه ملكه موسيقى
السلط توصف بانها اروع صوت خرج من
الولايات المتحده وسبب رغبه النساء في
الغناء